REEEEEEEEEEEE
hey how's it goin bros
wasn't that a cool intro??
I bet NONE of my editors could make it that cool (yeah right)
THat's right everybody
Because today's video is sponsered by LIKE app
Which is how I made this cool intro!
They also have no a bunch of superpower abilities
that you can use
Like fire breath!
hawwwww
lots of flame noises
flying rock
rock crashing
lightening
Nordic-swedish-thunder POWER
lightening sounds
Aaaand many many more!
It's really cool and I definitely recommend that you guys check it out
I was honestly having such a laugh
trying them out
if you wanna make them as well, it's very simple
you just place down the phone
wherever it's stable, you move
into the right frame and you just follow
the instructions on the screen
it's all motion based sooo
whatever motion you do, it follows
with the effects, it's really cool
it's like you actually have a superpower
we're also doing a give away of 10,000 dollars
that's right
So if you wanna know how to find that
you gotta keep watching
You can download the Like app, check out the link in the description
let's get going with the video everybady
*Clap clap*
MEME REVIEW everybody! Welcome to the show where I- I rvewvwvwvw [ruin] the memes.
*Crippling depression*
Ummmmmm..
FIRST MEME huehuehuehue it's so funny.
Sorry, I'm prematurely laughing. You don't even know what meme it is, yet!
The 15 minutes meme.
That's right...YES!
If the army doesn't show up in 15 minutes we're legally allowed to leave
hyuck hyuck hyuck
I didn't know this meme transcended internationals internationa- na NATIONS!
But basically it's the same in Sweden
If the teacher was late 15 minutes to class some dipshipshit
ME!!
Would say "Oh! Uh..if the teacher doesn't arrive in 15 minutes we're allowed to leave!!
This was declared in 1776.
"I hereby declare that if the teacher doesn't get to class in 15 minutes you're legally ALLOWED TO LEAVE IT'S THE LAW"
Thank you George Washington for- wait a minute
Das..das not George Washington, that's VSAUCE
*Vsauce emerging directly from hell* HEY VSAUCE
You just add Vsauce in anything these days, it's such a funny meme
I never did this!
It kinda annoys me I always try to get everyone riled up you know, before a battle like
"GUYS, COME ON! IT'S ALMOST 15 MINUTES AND IF WE ALL COMMIT TO IT errr I CAN'T BE THE ONLY ONE THAT LEAVES!"
"BUT IF WE ALL LEAVE COLLECTIVELY!"
"THEN WE'LL BE FINE!"
"TOGETHER WE ARE STRONG!"
"AND IT'S BOUND BY THE LAW GUYS!"
No one would ever listen to me :'(
If the baby doesn't arrive in 15 minutes we are legally allowed to leave
He makes a fair point
Because it's true
Everyone knows that
If the baby doesn't arrive, you don't have to take custody
Same sort of mental exercise is going on through in the egg
Wait, ha-has this vin-video been be- fif-
DAM IT!!1!
As he should
Because it is within his legality
They're legally allowed to leave guys!
FOURTEEN MINUTES!?!
F I F T E E N
HE'S LEGALLY ALLOWED TO NOT RAISE HIS STUPID FAMILY
(A very enraged pewds)
This meme gets a fifteen minutes
*clap*
Fifteen
It gets fift-fourteen out of fifteen
It's a great meme
It's clearly dead already
Ii -it-it stopped being funny even when I did the first one I'm like:
This really isn't that great
Why Lisa why Lisa please talk to me PLEASE
Literally all of my haters
All of them
They're always like:
(Hater voice) "All these memes are stale"
"His memes are always late"
"He's the last one to the meme"
"And err, quite frankly, I don't find him very funny"
(Swedish noises of redirection)
That's great
That's great that you think I'm last to the meme
Cuz all the sudden
All the SUDDEN
Out of nowhere
The Z U C C meme comes back?
*laughs* hoho yeah now it's funny?
Right after I invested millions and billions
Into the Mark Z U C C meme
Look at this, look at this, look when I did this video
29 OF OCTOBER 2017
And NOW you're all posting Z U C C memes
All like "Haha that's so funny!"
(pewdirage)
If you don't know what I'm talking about, I'll fill you in with the context
That's right
Cuz even if you are a normie pleb (REEEE)
I will enlighten you
I care about all my view-scewrs
This is so disturbing
He's a god dam giant
Why is he taking a photo of some chicken wings and potato fries?
There's nothing impressive about that
Its not some culinary gift
Look at his face!
Maybe this meme bounced back because - ah - recently
Mark has been in the media because ah things aren't going well for FaceBook.
Looks like Mark Zucced himself, am i right?
This all started because Mark did ahhhh - he got a question right
Here it is
You kind of need to remind yourself that you need to focus
and umm try to not let things bother you as much as possible
But it is going to bother you because your human
A N D  I  W A S  H U M A N
I am Human - still!
[Laughter from audience]
A light funny slip up you may say
Ah ho no no no no no
This is not the first time this has happened!
Thats right!
Are the allegations true that you are secretly a lizard?
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT - EVERYONE
So hes either a robot or a lizard person. (CC: Flameheart Eileen)